Here x equals negative 3. Excellent work if you found this number. This one was
tough. Now, the first thing to notice is that 125 is 5 raised to some exponent
and 8 is 2 raised to some exponent. So let's rewrite this numbers with bases of
5 for 125 and a base of 2 for 8. So, 125 is 5 cubed and 8 is 2 cubed. Now, I
can pull out this third power to have 5 halves raised to the third. The
left-hand side of the equation just stays the same. And notice we're so close
for these bases to be equal. We have 2 5ths on the left, but 5 halves on the
right. So, let's flip this base over. Let's do the reciprocal of it. Remember
that to flip over a base, or to make 5 halves become 2 5ths, we raise it to a
power of negative one. So, this exponent of 3 becomes negative 3. Now we have
identical bases of two-fifths, so x must equal negative three. The key idea to
solving this problem is to remember to flip over or take the reciprocal of a
base. To do that, we need a negative exponent.